oh hi
since sony launched its next generation
gaming handheld playstation vita last
december it's only sold a little over
two million of them and this has caused
sony to have to drastically cut its
forecasts for handheld gaming sales
meanwhile nintendo has sold about 17
million of nintendo 3ds and not to
mention all these smartphones and
tablets out there that are competing for
portable gaming time
in response sony last week told ign the
vita business is quote a marathon not a
sprint i couldn't disagree more falling
behind in the gaming hardware business
is death
just look at history can you name me one
successful video game console that
didn't explode out of the gates
atari's 2600 and nintendo's nes were
huge hits in their first christmas
seasons customers immediately understood
the value proposition they immediately
loved the gameplay sony's first
playstation never had to come from
behind even as a brand new entrant into
the market playstation got out ahead of
sega saturn it sold so many units that
nintendo late to the party could never
catch up if you don't come out of the
gate strong you're in big trouble
nintendo faced a very similar situation
with the 3ds it launched it at 250
that's what the vita cost and just like
the vita people weren't buying it so
what did nintendo do well it drastically
cut the price of the 3ds it put all of
its resources into finishing major 3ds
franchises which it got out for the
first crucial christmas season it
managed to get things turned around
there was a cost of this nintendo had
its first money losing year
ever because of the 3ds price drops but
it knows that in the long run it was
worth it
sony on the other hand has come out and
said it's not going to cut the price of
playstation vita this holiday people
don't want to buy playstation vita at
250 and 300
they're only gonna start buying it once
sony cuts the price
one vita game developer said last week
to gamma sutra quote
given how much time and money we have
invested into vita development i am
extremely concerned about our future as
a studio
and maybe that's the most important
point here
game developers don't have time to run a
marathon they need to be off to the
races now and if vita doesn't start out
soon they're gonna start looking for
other platforms that are sprinting to
the finish line
you